je propose qu'on commence mais mes chers
collègues mais mesdames messieurs
mesdames la rapporteur
notre commission d'enquête sur la
pénurie médicament et les choix de
l'industrie pharmaceutiques françaises
poursuit cet après-midi ces travaux on
accueillant les représentants des
centres de centrales d'achat de produits
de santé en milieu hospitalier le
groupement de coopération sanitaire GCS
uni-achat et le groupement intérêt
public réseau des acheteurs hospitaliers
résa
Renault Catelan directeur de l'ajeps
nous a déjà fourni un éclairage sur le
fonctionnement de tels organismes dont
le rôle est évidemment crucial dans la
chaîne de distribution du médicament
même si la GEPS nous a-t-il expliqué est
une direction acheteuse elle-même de
l'AP-HP et non une centrale d'achat
comme le sont les institutions que vous
représentez
l'uni achat union des hôpitaux pour les
achats et représentés par son directeur
général monsieur Walid Ben Brahim
accompagné des pharmaciens
coordonnateurs Madame Véronique Bardet
bruyères des Hospices Civils de Lyon et
Monsieur Audric Darras du CHU de
Toulouse
est une coopérative d'acheteurs
hospitalier public français l'un des
principaux acheteurs européens dans le
domaine de la santé et l'un des premiers
acheteurs publics français tous secteurs
d'activités confondus elle fut créée en
2005 par les Hospitaliers eux-mêmes dans
le but de mutualiser leurs achats et
leurs expertises elles regroupe
aujourd'hui
1312 établissements dont 123 groupements
hospitaliers de territoires les fameux
ght le groupement d'intérêt public Reza
quant à lui
est un autre opérateur majeur du secteur
il est représenté cet après-midi par
Madame Alexandra Denis directrice
générale adjointe
et par le docteur madame la docteur
Juliette jacobinatrice déjà des achats
de médicaments créés en 2007 pour
assurer la mutualisation des achats
hospitaliers pour la région
Île-de-France il a en 2016 à la demande
de la DGOS ou vers l'accès à ces marchés
à l'ensemble du territoire national
alors que le nombre de médicaments
connaissant des pénuries ou des risques
de pénurie des médicaments dit en
tension de ces d'augmenter et que
l'hôpital loin d'être prémuni contre ces
difficultés paraît en être tout
particulièrement affecté votre
témoignage est évidemment incontournable
c'est à l'hôpital nous ont dit plusieurs
des personnes que nous avons
auditionnées qu'il y a le plus de
pénurie
même si il semblerait qu'en période
d'épidémie et notamment le triple
épidémie les choses soient à relativiser
complètement mais or phase critique il y
a des sujets en tout cas il y a un
certain nombre de domaines
thérapeutiques dans lesquels c'est
l'hôpital qui est effectivement concerné
nous souhaitons donc que vous puissiez
dans un bref propos introductif
présentez votre analyse de la situation
actuelle exposée la façon dont les
organismes que vous représentez qui sont
des outils de rationalisation de
mutualisation et d'optimisation des
achats agissent pour prévenir et gérer
les ruptures d'approvisionnement de
produits de santé
notamment ici dans notre cas de les
médicaments et nous dire qu'elle
recommandations vous émettriez pour
qu'il soit mis fin à ce phénomène
désormais chroniques et je dirais
exponentielle puisque je vous le
rappelle lors de la mission
d'information du Sénat en 2018 nous
étions à peu près entre 600 et 700
médicaments en pénurie nous atteignons
les 2500 à 3000 suivant les territoires
suivants les lunettes que l'on chauffe
pour regarder
vous êtes pour créer notamment les
méthodes qui sous-tendent la passation
des marchés publics en matière de
fourniture de médicaments il a été fait
référence devant nous à des politiques
d'achat et à des critères d'attribution
donc je mets entre guillemets se reprend
le verbatim de certaines auditions
d'attributions dangereux le phénomène
des mégas appel d'offres hospitalier
étant notamment régulièrement pointé du
doigt
ce problème est d'ailleurs bien
documenté et la mission d'information
sénatoriale de 2018 dans son rapport
soulier déjà que notre politique de
rationalisation des achats de
médicaments hospitaliers en privilégiant
la massification des appels d'offres à
entraîné une raréfaction des
fournisseurs et la multiplication
subséquente des difficultés
d'approvisionnement vous nous direz si
ce constat que monsieur catland a semblé
relativiser vous paraît toujours
d'actualité je vais accéder à chacun la
parole pour un propos d'environ en 5
minutes par institution je donnerai
ensuite j'insiste sur les 5 minutes je
donnerai ensuite la parole à Madame
Laurence Cohen rapporter heureux de
notre commission d'enquête qui vous
posera une première série de questions
je précise que cette audition est
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat et qu'elle fait l'objet d'un
compte rendu publié
avant de vous donner la parole je dois
vous rappeler qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission d'enquête et
passible des peines prévues aux articles
434-13 434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal je
vous invite donc à prêter successivement
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité en levant la main droite et en
disant je le jure monsieur Ben Brahim
je vous remercie et Monsieur le
Directeur Général vous avez la porte
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente et
Messieurs alors effectivement je vais
commencer par présenter brièvement le
GCS Unis achat une achat comme vous
l'avez précisé a été un groupement
public qui a été créé en 2005
par les hôpitaux et pour les hôpitaux
c'est un modèle original sous forme de
groupement de coopération sanitaire une
échelle nationale avec aujourd'hui vous
l'avez vous l'avez dit près de 1300
adhérents principalement des
établissements de santé établissements
publics de santé très majoritaire
un ADN très important d'ancrage très
fort dans les hôpitaux publics qui sont
en quelque sorte ses actionnaires
puisque le conseil d'administration est
composé de représentants des
établissements publics de santé et
présidé par un directeur d'hôpital
un ADN d'ancrage qui se traduit par une
organisation très originelle autour de
13 sites de production de marché il y a
un siège qui est situé à Lyon et ensuite
les acheteurs et notamment les
pharmaciens ont une partie est avec moi
aujourd'hui
sont dans les hôpitaux auprès des
équipes hospitalières ce qui permet
c'est très important un vrai ancrage une
vraie qualification du besoin des
hôpitaux au plus près de leur
préoccupations avec un modèle de
groupement de commande notamment qui a
fait ses preuves et qui permet de
collecter de manière vraiment très fine
les besoins des hôpitaux et d'agréger
aujourd'hui un volume d'achat qui sont
passés par via les marchés du ni achat
d'un total de 6 milliards d'euros en
2022 dont 4 milliards pas loin de 4
milliards d'euros pour les produits de
santé qui constituent effectivement la
première activité du niasha médicament
et dispositifs médicaux confondus une
achat également d'autres activités
notamment des activités d'achat
d'énergie qui sont très importantes
biologiques biomédicales de matériel et
de prestations de service pour le compte
là aussi de ces de ces adhérents
alors je reviendrai d'abord sur la
notion de taille critique qui me paraît
importante et notamment les notions qui
ont été abordées en lien avec le sujet
des pénuries de médicaments
à l'origine il n'y achat était
effectivement créé pour massifier les
achats hospitaliers donc en 2005 dans un
contexte où on demandait aux hôpitaux et
donc les hôpitaux ont créé cet outil
pour faire des économies et faire faire
des économies aux établissements de
santé c'était le l'objectif affiché dans
un marché pharmaceutique notamment
mondialisé pour donner un ordre de
grandeur aujourd'hui le marché
pharmaceutique mondial représente 1300
milliards d'euros donc vous imaginez
qu'avec similaire même 4 milliards
d'euros d'achat pardon sur les produits
de santé nous représentants moins de
0,3% du marché mondial ce qui
effectivement pèse finalement assez peu
compte tenu des enjeux et des niveaux de
discussion que nous avons avec des
industriels de très gros de très grosses
tailles
aujourd'hui
uniasha a une taille critique suffisante
nécessaire et nous le défendons pour
faire face aux enjeux qui traversent le
sujet de la chasse publique pour les
hôpitaux le sujet des gains financiers
des économies et vraiment aujourd'hui
n'est plus le premier enjeu n'est plus
l'enjeu principal c'est un enjeu
important et les hôpitaux comptent sur
nous pour faire ce qu'on appelle
notamment des gains sur achat mais aussi
et on en vient au sujet des pénuries
compte sur uniachat pour sécuriser leurs
approvisionnements compte sur une achat
pour décarboner leurs activités manière
très très précise et ce qu'on peut faire
aujourd'hui avec la taille critique du
niasha c'est plus plusieurs choses
d'abord mobiliser on pourrait y revenir
au gré de vos questions des techniques
contractuelles qui sont très différentes
et qui nécessitent une vraie expertise
une maturité qui vont aussi prendre du
temps pour les hospitaliers en
équipement on a des études qui nous
montrent qu'aujourd'hui un hôpital peut
consacrer jusqu'à un équivalent en plein
de pharmacien à gérer
pour le compte de ses adhérents et donc
c'est du temps aussi qu'on rend aux
pharmacies hospitalières on mobilise des
techniques de dite de multiatribution
quand on dit des mégas Apple d'offres
moi je sais pas vraiment ce que c'est un
mégapole d'offre à une achat on définit
des stratégies d'achat segment par
segment on découpe nos marchés par
aire-thérapeutique et on définit des
stratégies d'achat qui sont très souvent
de la multi attribution donc il est fini
le temps où on attribuait uniquement à
un industriel une seule un seul marché
pour tous les hôpitaux français on a ces
techniques qui ont été notamment
préconisées après la crise covid on fait
évoluer le poids des critères et
aujourd'hui on a sur certains appels
d'offres le critère de prix dont on
parliez tout à l'heure qui représente
qui peut représenter 30% de la note
totale donc c'est pas une part
prépondérante c'est une part importante
parce que on est là pour acheter les
médicaments et les dispositifs médicaux
aux meilleurs prix mais on fait aussi la
part belle à d'autres critères sur le
développement durable et la sécurisation
des approvisionnements notamment on a la
capacité aussi de mobiliser des marchés
une achat était la première centrale à
mobiliser dans le cadre de notre
consortium avec le collègue du raisin à
côté de moi un marché souverain pour les
masques et qui a retenu des fabricants
européens avec la clause de souveraineté
européenne que nous avons été les
premiers à mettre en place on a
également et c'est le deuxième élément
sur la taille critique une capacité
d'être présent et d'être là pour
répondre aux situations de crise là
aussi on pourra y revenir nos acheteurs
ont été très présents dans la cellule de
crise pendant la gestion de du covid
avec une très bonne connaissance du
tissu industriel une connaissance et une
capacité à aller chercher des sourcils à
aller voilà vraiment éclairer là aussi
les pouvoirs publics sur sur les achats
qui étaient nécessaires dans cette
période prétendue et puis dans une crise
dont on a peu entendu parler notamment
sur les médicaments dérivés du sang à la
fin 2021 une capacité auprès des
pouvoirs publics à aller
le piloter un contingentement dans une
période où on avait une pénurie de
médicaments dérivée du sang qui aurait
pu mettre en péril des prises en charge
et qui a été gérée auprès des pouvoirs
publics par les acheteurs du ni achat on
pourra y revenir tout à l'heure enfin
nos propositions et là aussi nous
pourrons y revenir d'évolution et nos
préconisations qui sont aussi permises
avec ce niveau de maturité et
d'expertise elle tourne autour d'une
évolution de notre positionnement et
nous travaillons maintenant depuis
plusieurs années autour de la gestion
potentielle et future pour le compte de
nos adhérents puisque ce sont nos
adhérents qui nous ont demandé des
approvisionnements en produits de santé
aujourd'hui nous achetons un médicament
nous achetons avec l'approvisionnement
qui est géré par l'industriel et
aujourd'hui à l'instar de ce que fait
l'ajep ce que vous avez cité tout à
l'heure nous travaillons à organiser
l'approvisionnement en produits de santé
pour le compte de nos adhérents ce qui
nous donnera des leviers complémentaires
notamment des leviers de constitution
réel de stock réel puisque aujourd'hui
nous avons des stocks contractualisés
chez nos fournisseurs nous pourrons
mobiliser des stock modèle avec ce
levier supplémentaire ce qui est un
levier de contrera les pénuries et puis
des évolutions là aussi dans les
thématiques d'achat souverain qui sont
très importantes pour une achat et sur
lesquels nous avons déjà travaillé sur
des sujets notamment de masque nous
avons l'ambition et le propositions de
créer une filière d'achat souverain qui
permettra de coordonner les actions des
différents acheteurs qui aujourd'hui
effectivement l'achat hospitalier est
encore assez assez éclaté et nous avons
l'ambition grâce à notre expertise et
notre savoir-faire en la matière de
coordonner les différentes initiatives
de porter des appels d'offres
spécifiques pour là aussi être auprès
des pouvoirs publics le bras armé de la
politique de réindustrialisation et de
souveraineté sanitaire française voilà
pour mon propos introductif que j'espère
n'avoir pas été trop long
je vous remercie madame Denis
donc le raisin est un groupement
d'intérêt public comme vous l'avez dit
on a été créé effectivement en 2007 on
était un opérateur régional pour la
région Île-de-France on est à la fois
central d'achat mais on a également un
centre de ressources et d'expertise ce
qui veut dire qu'on a deux objectifs à
la fois la mutualisation des achats mais
également la professionnalisation de la
fonction achat
on a aujourd'hui plus de 2000
établissements avec lesquels on
travaille évidemment du secteur
hospitalier principalement mais aussi
toutes sortes d'entités qui agissent
dans le domaine sanitaire médico-social
et social
qui représente environ 2 milliards
d'euros d'achat mutualisés mutualisé par
an et la partie couverte par les
médicaments puisque c'est l'objet de nos
échanges de ce jour et d'environ 830
millions d'euros par an
on tient beaucoup au terme de
mutualisation des achats et non pas à
celui de massification parce que si
évidemment il y a un regroupement des
quantités il y a également un
regroupement des expertises donc le
raisin apporte de l'expertise à la fois
pharmaceutique achat juridique
logistique de l'expertise en système
d'information donc ça c'est un point
important donc on appuie vraiment la
mutualisation des achats et pas
simplement la massification et la mise
en commun de quantité
la centrale d'achat du raisin a été
labellisée relations fournisseur acha
responsable en 2021 donc c'est un label
qui est décerné par le médiateur des
entreprises
qui fait que ont été reconnus des
qualités de relation durable et
équilibrée avec les fournisseurs donc
voilà on a bâti l'ensemble de nos
politiques achats et notre organisation
d'achat autour des
items de ce label
nous sommes un opérateur national depuis
2016 comme vous l'avez indiqué mais nous
n'agissons pas toujours au niveau
national nous adaptons notre politique
achat en fonction des segments d'achat
puisque nous couvrons l'ensemble des
segments d'achat des besoins des
hôpitaux pour les médicaments en
l'occurrence nous agissons au niveau
régional de manière historique mais
toujours encore aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que nous mutualisons nos mutualisons les
procédures d'achat pour la région
Île-de-France pour les hôpitaux de la
région Île-de-France qui soit public ou
privés dans lucratif
et nous mutualiseurs mutualisons
également les achats à travers une
procédure pour les établissements de la
région Normandie donc ce sont deux
procédures d'achat différentes on
travaille avec environ 90 hôpitaux pour
le marché
Île-de-France et 60 pour le marché
normand
en termes de technique de technique
d'achat c'est ces procédures au niveau
régional suivre les préconisations du
programme phare de la direction générale
de l'offre de soins qui préconise pour
les achats de médicaments en concurrence
de faire un achat au niveau régional
donc je laisserai de côté la partie des
médicaments en monopole d'autant plus
que nos observons que les ruptures sont
les plus courantes sur les médicaments
dit concurrentiels qui représentent 25%
environ du montant les achats de
médicaments
nos coordonnateurs à chat et le docteur
Jacob en fait partie font des
préconisations d'alternatives lorsqu'il
y a des ruptures aux adhérents que ce
soit pour le groupement francilien ou
pour le groupement
nous avons pendant longtemps aussi basé
nos appels d'offres sur un critère prix
en visant des gains sur achat mais
depuis notamment depuis la crise
sanitaire nous avons fait rentrer
d'autres éléments notamment des critères
de sécurisation liées aux modes de
production
et sur certains autres segments d'achat
les masques ont été cités mais nous nous
portons la procédure des gants dans le
cadre du consortium avec une achat des
clauses de souveraineté européenne
nous avons mis en place plusieurs
systèmes également dans nos appels
d'offres assez assez classique et qui
ont déjà été cités par plusieurs
intervenants à cette commission de type
des pénalités des achats pour compte
Frédéric etc
notre première recommandation serait de
travailler sur la provisionnement sur la
gestion des flux et des stocks on pense
que c'est une réserve de performance
importante et ça entraîne pour nous de
lancer des réflexions sur la création de
pharmacies à usage intérieur de
territoires au moins sur certains types
de médicaments en s'appuyant sur des
prestataires externes de type
dépositaire pour gérer ses pharmacies
les hôpitaux d'un territoire pourraient
choisir un dépositaire commun et quand
je dis hôpitaux d'un territoire ce sera
la notion de territoire et bien sûr à
définir elle pourrait être alignée sur
celle du groupement hospitalier de
territoire bien sûr
notre deuxième recommandation qui est
celle que nous avons déjà faite dans le
cadre du groupe de travail auquel nous
participons de de construction de la
nouvelle feuille de route de pour lutter
contre les pénuries améliorées la
disponibilité des médicaments en France
que mène au ministère de la Santé et de
mettre en place une coord une
coordination forte par l'État sur les
achats de médicaments qui pourraient
conduire à la mise en commun de moyens
et d'expertise on pense que c'est
vraiment la mise en commun des moyens
d'expertise qui qui est la clé avec la
mise en place d'un opérateur national
unique qui coordonnerait l'ensemble des
parties prenantes donc il faudrait qu'il
y a un rôle fort de l'État et une
participation de l'ensemble des acteurs
des opérateurs à chat tels que ceux qui
sont là aujourd'hui la PHP la NSM santé
publique France les parties prenantes
l'objectif serait de mettre en place une
politique à chaque cohérente au niveau
national avec éventuellement des
déclinaisons régionales et de la mettre
en œuvre
cette idée nous est venue notamment de
dans le cadre des échanges qu'on mène
avec d'autres centrales d'achat
hospitalière européenne puisqu'on est
membre fondateur de l'association et
Pâques et une association qui regroupe
des centrales d'achats hospitalier
européenne et des exemples d'autres pays
il y a un opérateur unique national en
Norvège au Danemark et il y a une
politique nationale qui est déclinée
régionalement en Angleterre donc c'est
un exemple qu'on peut regarder avec un
rôle du pharmacien régional qui apporte
son soutien dans la gestion des pénuries
la plupart des pays européens avec
laquelle on a avec lesquels on a échangé
on renforcé la centralisation depuis la
crise sanitaire et par ailleurs on a
beaucoup d'échanges avec la Commission
européenne également qui qui a eu
beaucoup de problèmes de coordination de
l'ensemble des acteurs pendant la crise
sanitaire et qui verrait d'un intérêt
fort le fait qu'on puisse parler d'une
seule voix au niveau français voilà donc
c'est je pense dans le cadre de
l'ensemble de ces réflexions que on
réitère cette proposition d'opérateurs
d'opérateurs uniques coordonnées par
l'État qu'il faudrait mettre en place
très bien je vous remercie je vais
donner immédiatement la parole à notre
rapporteur Laurence Cohen pour une
première série de questions et peut-être
quelques précisions sur les propos tenus
oui merci
Madame et Monsieur pour vos propos
introductifs qui brossent bien
finalement le champ de vos compétences
peut-être de précisions donc pour
Monsieur la première pour Monsieur
valide Ben Brahim si vous avez parlé
d'une d'avoir l'ambition de la création
d'une filière d'achat souverain
j'aimerais que vous nous en disiez plus
c'est à dire sur quoi exactement et
madame Denis vous venez de parler
finalement concernant
l'approvisionnement de la votre
recommandation sur une pharmacie interne
liée au territoire je voudrais également
avoir des précisions c'est à dire est-ce
qu'il s'agit en réalité de
ce que fait lajeps ou ce que faisait
lajeps puisque petit à petit
malheureusement elle a de moins en moins
de de possibilités et elle se heurte
quand même au fait que normalement elle
doit elle doit puisse retrouver sur le
sur le terrain concurrentiel donc ce
sont ces précisions là et je vais
enchaîner pardonnez-moi et je vais
enchaîner sur sur des questions
concernant les tensions
d'approvisionnement et les ruptures de
stove de stock pardon quelle situation
vous ont paru les plus marquantes au
cours des dernières années par lors
durée ou par le risque encouru pour le
patient et notamment avoir des
précisions sur les types de produits qui
étaient les plus concernés et j'entends
j'entends par là effectivement le niveau
des classes thérapeutiques et ça veut
dire c'est bien les génériques sous
brevet ou les produits nature
du coup quel est l'impact de ces
situations
donc sur les finances hospitalières quel
coût ça
vous avez parlé vous avez tenu à nous
préciser le fait que vous vous parliez
de mutualisation
des achats ce qui ouvrait effectivement
un champ plus plus important mais quels
sont les avantages que vous voyez à ces
mutualisations et qu'elles sont aussi
les inconvénients
il y a peut-être un petit souci c'est
consistant pardon à la structuration de
l'achat publique la structuration de
l'achat public hospitalier voit la
coexistence de plusieurs entités
juridiques d'ailleurs que vous avez
nommé dans vos propos introductifs que
ce soit la geppes donc une achat lugap
et est-ce que ça vous paraît
satisfaisant du point de vue de la
prévention et de la gestion des pénuries
des médicaments
ma cinquième question et vous madame
vous l'avez dit au niveau du raisin vous
avez parlé du programme PHARE
et donc ce programme qui a été mis en
oeuvre par la DGOS depuis octobre 2000
2011 et il semble placer la recherche
d'économies au centre de l'achat
hospitalier donc qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez là encore quels sont les blocages
les limites
sixième question qu'en est-il du critère
du lieu d'implantation des sites de
production qui sont consacrés par
l'article 65 de la loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour 2022 et je
pense notamment à d'autres critères qui
peuvent être relatifs à la
responsabilité sociale et
environnementale est-ce que ces
critères-là interviennent dans les
auditions que nous avons eu nous
certains de nos interlocuteurs nous ont
beaucoup parlé effectivement de ces
critères sociaux et environnementaux et
le fait que les entreprises soient
délocalisées dans un certain nombre de
pays qui n'ont pas les mêmes exigences
que la France ou que les pays européens
pouvaient entraîner justement des des
ruptures d'égalité en relocalisation en
relocalisant pardon sur le sol français
est-ce que vous pensez que le rôle des
acheteurs peut être éventuellement
d'accompagner une politique industrielle
donc de relocalisation ça va avec ce que
je vous ai dit précédemment
relocalisation en France mais aussi au
niveau de l'Union européenne nous avons
encore insisté ce matin lors de nos
notre audition avec Madame Bachelot sur
le fait que effectivement il y avait une
nécessité de relocaliser en France mais
en même temps on n'était pas axés sur
franco-français et qu'il fallait avoir
une vue européenne et qui avait la
nécessité qu'il y ait justement une
coordination pour qu'il y ait
une efficacité plus grande
mon autre question elle elle touche sur
le caractère on nous a signalé le
caractère disons trop massif des appels
d'offres hospitalier est-ce que
finalement vous vous qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez et est-ce que vous avez une
attention en tout cas spéciale
particulière face à la à ce problème et
notamment en étant très attentif à la
diversification
des fournisseurs enfin je suis presque
arrivé au bout de mes questions mais
est-ce que il vous arrive de constater a
posteriori d'ailleurs que des
laboratoires ont pris des engagements
qu'il n'était pas certain de tenir mais
ils l'ont fait parce qu'il voulait
remporter des marchés importants et
est-ce que ça nous a été signalé est-ce
qu'il est vous avez pu voir qu'un
certain nombre de distributeurs
finalement choisissent de s'engager sur
la fournit de volume sans être toujours
capable d'en assurer la continuité la
qualité est-ce que vous avez des
exemples précis à nous donner
enfin les conditions tarifaires de
l'achat de médicaments aux industriels
par les établissements de santé est-ce
que ça contribue à la création de
situations de pénurie ou pas qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez et la toute dernière
question c'est dans son rapport sur
l'application des lois de financement de
la sécurité sociale qui a été publiée en
septembre 2017 la Cour des comptes
préconisait de mettre fin au régime de
liberté des prix propre aux
établissements de santé et de mettre en
quelque sorte en place un régime commun
à la ville et à l'hôpital en confiance
au CEPS la fixation du prix des
médicaments hospitaliers sur le modèle
d'ailleurs du prix administré des
médicaments remboursables qui sont
dispensés par les officines de ville
qu'elle pourrait être les avantages
d'une telle évolution du point de vue de
la lutte contre les pénuries et vous qui
êtes au cœur du système est-ce que vous
y êtes favorable ou pas quels sont les
avantages et les inconvénients donc
beaucoup de questions pardonnez-moi vous
êtes vous pouvez vous partager
évidemment les réponses pour que chacun
puisse finalement apporter des
précisions au questionnements que j'ai
fait mais qui vont être suivies par
d'autres questions de mes collègues je
vous remercie
merci alors si je pouvais me permettre
de démarrer je vais répondre à quelques
questions dans le désordre mais avec un
fil conducteur que vous verrez assez
clair la première question à laquelle
j'ai envie de répondre c'est la
quatrième sur la multiplicité des
structures d'achat publique à l'hôpital
ça me paraît important de commencer par
ça parce qu'effectivement c'est une
disons une curiosité
à laquelle on est confronté notamment
quand on discute avec d'autres
administrations qui ont unifié leurs
achats mais c'est un état de fait qui
aujourd'hui a été construite une
nombreuses années vous voyez qu'on cette
façade des institutions il y en a
d'autres qui ont plusieurs dizaines
d'années de de vie et moi mon sentiment
face à ça c'est que il faut se méfier
d'une solution simple qui pourquoi elle
consistait à dire on met tout le monde
sous le même drapeau et on crée une
super structure qui va qui va tout gérer
ça me paraît pas forcément la bonne
réponse très complexe long à mettre en
œuvre et puis peut-être une couche
supplémentaire qui qui serait pas
forcément très efficace parce que
derrière il y a quand même une notion
d'urgence face à un certain nombre de
constats et il faut être pour moi
pragmatique et efficace la façon de
faire pour répondre à votre à votre
première question revenir sur une
proposition d'achat souverain ce qui est
important par rapport au rôle de l'État
et j'ai entendu les propositions de mes
de mes collègues à côté de moi le rôle
de l'État l'État sur ces sujets là à mon
sens bien sûr c'est mon avis doit être
doit être stratège pas opérateur l'État
doit définir ce que c'est la stratégie
de souveraineté définir quelles sont les
segments prioritaires
définir des objectifs à atteindre dans
une stratégie d'achat souverain et
évaluer les objectifs sont atteints ou
pas et ensuite les opérateurs d'achat et
c'est différent et je pense que ces
opérateurs là ne doivent pas être
confondues avec avec l'État
peuvent ensuite agir et pour ce qu'on
considère nous comme étant aujourd'hui
une priorité c'est à dire la création
d'une filière d'achat c'est-à-dire d'une
équipe d'acheteurs et notamment de
pharmaciens dont on dispose aujourd'hui
nous avons 20 pharmaciens spécialistes
des achats dont certains sont d'ores et
déjà partants pour pour constituer cette
équipe serait à la fois de conduire des
appels d'offres spécifiques quand l'État
définit une entreprise qu'il faut dont
il faut sauvegarder l'activité quand
l'État identifie des segments
prioritaires notamment par rapport à ce
qui a été vu pendant la crise covid et
des médicaments critiques dont on n'a
pas eu le bénéfice pendant plusieurs
jours parfois ou sur lesquels on était
obligé de contingenter nous demande de
faire des appels d'offres spécifiques et
à côté de ça d'organiser de structurer
de faire en sorte que l'ensemble des
acteurs du système et de cet écosystème
qui effectivement paraît un peu un peu
éclaté et bien puisse monter en
compétences puis cette coordonnée et
qu'on est cette cette filière qui soit à
la fois productrice d'appel d'offres
spécifiques dédiées à la souveraineté et
qui aide à monter à faire monter en
charge et à faire monter en compétences
en expertise l'ensemble des acheteurs
hospitaliers dont certains sont très
démunis vous imaginez que parfois on a
des groupements régionaux il y a un
pharmacien pour un groupement régional
qui doit piloter des appels d'offres
pour des dizaines d'établissements donc
c'est pas possible pour lui de tout
mener et notamment d'arriver à ce niveau
d'expertise sur l'achat s'ouvre pour
répondre à une autre question oui une
centrale d'achat et c'est dans la
continuité doit être le bras armé de
l'État dans la politique de
réindustrialisation et de souveraineté
sanitaire ça c'est notre positionnement
et nous on est prêt à le faire et on a
fait ses propositions là les
relocalisations elles sont aujourd'hui
stimulées par l'offre et l'État aide des
industriels et c'est tant mieux à se
réimplanter ou à maintenir leur activité
en France mais il faut aussi stimuler la
demande et c'est là où nous pouvons agir
et c'est là où nous avons toute notre
légitimité pour organiser grâce à notre
réseau puisque nous avons sur certains
appels d'offres nous avons 450 500
hôpitaux qui sont avec nous sur l'appel
d'offres on peut faire boule de neige et
structurer une demande qui va sécuriser
le débouché pour un industriel mais ça
répond à une autre de vos questions ça
n'est malheureusement pas souvent
souvent pas suffisant puisque des
industriels avec lesquels nous discutons
aujourd'hui sur des projets de
réindustrialisation nous disent vous
n'avez pas même avec tous les hôpitaux
que vous avez vous n'aurez pas
l'évolution pour nous garantir une
production et donc il faut avoir une
approche européenne c'est indispensable
et cette politique de souveraineté elle
ne peut que se construire dans cette
dans cet environnement européen je
laisse peut-être mes collègues répondent
sur les sujets un peu plus précis
notamment donner des exemples de pénurie
un peu emblématique et puis répondre à
d'autres questions le temps que je
reprenne mon souffle
oui merci de ce temps d'échange moi je
voudrais profiter de cet instant pour
faire un témoignage de ma pratique
puisque je suis avant tout praticien
hospitalier au sein d'un CHU et que donc
je trouve qu'il y a un paradoxe quand on
dit les médias appel d'offres génèrent
des pénuries
on vous a donné quelques chiffres malgré
nos quatre milliards d'achats pour
inhachat à l'échelle mondiale on ne
représente rien on représente moins de
0,5% donc on est absolument pas visible
et si je prends l'exemple des
médicaments dérivés du plasma dont j'ai
eu j'ai été amenée à m'occuper de façon
extrêmement pragnante si nous n'avions
pas eu cette cette dimension au niveau
du territoire national je pense que il y
aura eu
des difficultés beaucoup plus aiguës
pour nos patients je parle notamment de
la pénurie en immunoglobuline volumine
enfin je veux pas rentrer trop dans des
détails mais nous avons donc pu de par
la connaissance que nous avons de nos
adhérents et des besoins de nos
adhérents qui nous ont alerté
immédiatement mais de façon très fine
avec les coordes de patients avec les
indications pouvoir évaluer
véritablement les besoins nous sommes
évidemment en lien direct avec les
fournisseurs ou c'est que des
fractionneurs il y en a très peu ça se
compte sur la poignée d'une main au
niveau mondial on a le chance d'avoir un
fractionneur français donc avec lequel
nous entretenons des relations
extrêmement étroites qui malheureusement
a un problème de de d'outils industriels
qui est qui est défaillant qui est en
cours de de
réhabilitation enfin de reconstruction
donc les choses ne peuvent que
s'améliorer mais donc il a fallu
composer avec toutes ces dimensions là
et donc avec la NSM et avec la DGOS
puisque nous avons travaillé évidemment
en collaboration étroite avec ses
services là nous avons pu dire voilà
nous sommes arrivés à capter tel volume
de médicaments dérivés du plasma et donc
là il ne s'agissait pas de mettre en
concurrence l'idée c'était d'aller
chercher tous les volumes que tous les
fractionneurs pouvaient nous fournir
voir d'aller chercher des molécules à
l'export et d'obtenir de la part de la
NSM des autorisations d'importation et
là je rentrerai pas dans la mécanique
des prix puisque là pour le coup on est
sur des prix administrés et donc on a eu
une autre problématique et à partir du
moment où on avait réuni ces volumes là
avec la DGOS établissements par
établissement on a dit ben voilà on va
donner tant de grammes à tel CHU tant de
grammes à tel CHU et on a fait ça tous
les mois pendant quasiment un an et ça
on a pu le faire parce que effectivement
on a pu rassembler les besoins de nos
adhérents du terrain on est en proximité
avec nos fournisseurs et donc on a pu
concaténer ces données et faire en sorte
de passer
cette écueil qui aurait pu être
extrêmement douloureux le mieux possible
ce n'est on a gagné une bataille on n'a
pas gagné la guerre je serai je vais pas
faire un péché d'optimisme enfin voilà
donc c'est ce qui nous
[Musique]
je vais laisser mon confrère donner un
autre exemple pratique alors avant je
voulais peut-être témoigner notamment
sur le l'ingénierie contractuel qui
conduit à diversifier les sources
d'approvisionnement puisque c'était une
des questions et nous avons donc recours
de manière très massive à de la multi
attribution sous différentes formes
toutes les formes de multi attribution
ne se prémunissent pas de
des ruptures d'approvisionnement il y a
une forme qui a à nos yeux un intérêt
qui est la multi attribution qui permet
de répartir des volumes simultanément
sur plusieurs sur plusieurs fournisseurs
et qui a
deux prérequis à sa mise en oeuvre
le premier c'est l'évaluation bon alors
évidemment sur des molécules qui
justifient qui ont une criticité
intrinsèque du fait de leur place dans
l'arsenal thérapeutique évidemment
éventuellement un passif de rupture
d'approvisionnement il nous
sélectionnons ces molécules et qui
relèvent du champ concurrentiel
le nous avons donc
recours pour ces molécules à condition
qu'un nous ayons un volume de
mutualisation qui soit suffisant et du
coup c'est plutôt une à une force de
mutualiser ces volumes et nous nous
sommes attentifs à des volumes qui sont
suffisamment mutualisés massifiés pas
tant en valeur absolue mais en valeur
relative sur notre poids sur le marché
français donc c'est pas une
dimensionnement économique ou par
rapport à un nombre du CD c'est le poids
que l'on représente qui détermine notre
capacité ou notre intérêt à répartir ces
volumes sur plusieurs acteurs ça c'est
le premier aspect évidemment dans cette
pratique nous ne devons pas conduire à
multiplier les références au sein d'un
même établissement
qui se traduirait outre par-delà des
organisations par un risque de d'usage
en interne et les conditions qui qui
sont
qui sont exigés finalement pour avoir
recours à cette multi attribution infini
c'est évidemment que nos fournisseurs
n'est pas la même chaîne
d'approvisionnement puisque on peut
retenir plusieurs fournisseurs
différents mais qui se trouvent avoir la
même structure de de production et ça
c'est ça serait un écueil et puis
que cela ne se traduise pas non plus par
une dégradation sur d'autres aspects
notamment sur la qualité
les critères de qualité des produits que
nous retenons ou une dégradation d'ordre
économique qui ne justifierait pas le la
le recours à une deuxième source
peut-être pour préciser un petit peu
donc nous répartissons sur les molécules
que nous jouons donc critiques et qui
sont donc une short liste de médicaments
d'usage essentiellement hospitaliers
les volumes sur des groupes des zones
géographiques des arts géographiques
avec donc un fournisseur pour une zone à
notre fournisseur pour une autre sous
réserve que les conditions que j'ai
évoquées soient réunies
voilà pour la première
passer la parole à Madame Tony merci
beaucoup
régional puisqu'on n'aura pas forcément
les mêmes contraintes sur l'ensemble des
territoires concernant les avantages et
inconvénients de la mutualisation
comme je l'avais dit tout à l'heure il y
a une notion de mise en commun
d'expertise et un des gros avantages de
la mutualisation c'est de pouvoir avoir
des experts sur l'ensemble des sujets
qui sont traités l'ensemble des axes de
ces sujets que ce soit des pharmaciens
des logisticiens des juristes puisque il
y a des techniques juridiques liées à la
commande publique qui sont assez fortes
donc voilà c'est un avantage très fort
de la mutualisation c'est la
mutualisation de l'expertise c'est pas
possible d'avoir des experts dans chaque
groupement régional pas possible d'avoir
des équipes
assez nombreuses de pharmaciens dans
l'ensemble des groupements régionaux
chose qu'on peut faire sur des
groupements à l'échelle par exemple des
opérateurs qui sont présents
s'agissant du programme PHARE vous avez
évoqué le fait qu'effectivement les
gains sur achat étaient un élément
central du programme PHARE
ce qui est ce qui est ce qui était vrai
au début ce qui est pour partie toujours
le cas aujourd'hui mais ils ont fait
rentrer beaucoup de nouvelles
thématiques qui
s'adresse aussi les achats de produits
de santé donc notamment les chantiers
liés à la logistique à
l'approvisionnement les achats
responsables donc voilà je pense qu'il y
aura toujours ce volet gain sur achat
puisque c'est quand même un programme à
vocation également économique et qui est
encore des efforts à faire pas forcément
sur le le sujet qui est le nôtre
aujourd'hui mais sur d'autres segments
d'achat oui et avec de nouvelles
considérations qui sont entrées
progressivement dans le cadre dans le
cadre du programme
et enfin s'agissant du fait qu'il y ait
plusieurs opérateurs la question pour
pour nous comme vous l'avez compris et
pas tant le le nombre d'opérateurs mais
plutôt la façon
dont ces opérateurs devant ces
opérateurs vont réaliser leur achats et
mettre en œuvre des politiques achats au
niveau à plusieurs à plusieurs niveaux
oui alors du coup nous aussi dans nos
établissements outre les molécules qui
ont été enfin impactés pendant la crise
covid ou forcément nos établissements
également ont été impactés également
l'amoxicilline et le paracétamol l'hiver
dernier j'ai en tête de grosse classe
thérapeutiques fortement impacté par les
ruptures mes collègues du ni achat en
ont parlé c'est les immunoglobulines
polyvalente
c'est donc médicament dérivé du sang ça
ça a été un impact très très fort pour
nos établissements et en consortium on a
travaillé fortement avec les
fournisseurs justement pour établir voir
comment de manière pérenne on pouvait on
pouvait référencer les différents
fournisseurs diversifiés justement pour
éviter aussi l'assèchement de la
concurrence donc là on est partis sur
les appels d'offres on a quatre
fournisseurs en fonction des
spécificités des immunoglobulines
le deuxième point où là nous en tant que
resa établissement du raisin on a été
impacté récemment c'est sur les solutés
massifs et donc là justement on a une
rupture puisque un laboratoire titulaire
de notre marché
a été en difficulté financière et donc
grâce à notre procédure d'achat que nous
avons au raisin qui est le système
d'acquisition dynamique nous avons pu
relancer rapidement un marché pour
pouvoir référencer un nouveau titulaire
dans un temps imparti court pour ne pas
continuer la rupture d'approvisionnement
voilà
on a eu une rupture annoncée donc à peu
près en décembre dernier on a un nouveau
titulaire là qui commence le marché en
ce qui nous a permis d'avoir une
continuité et rapidement un nouveau
titulaire de marché
merci pour pour vos réponses mais je
suis toujours en attente sur trois
quatre questions mais je vous en avais
posé beaucoup donc j'aimerais avoir plus
de précisions sur les situations de
tension
d'approvisionnement une rupture de stock
qui vous ont paru les plus marquantes
ces dernières ces dernières années donc
vous l'avez dit vous l'avez dit un peu
mais il y a pas je pense qu'il y a pas
que ça vous n'avez pas à me semble-t-il
répondu sur finalement l'impact de cette
de ces situations sur les finances
hospitalières ça ça me paraît quand même
assez important
et en concernant le les critères qui
pourraient entrer en ligne de compte et
je pense je vous avais signifié
notamment les les critères concernant
l'environnement et les critères
également sociaux donc l'implantation
des sites de la production et enfin vous
n'avez pas non plus à me semble-t-il
répondu au fait de que nous avons pu
constater que certains certains
laboratoires prennent des engagements
parce qu'ils veulent absolument avoir le
marché mais en réalité ils n'ont pas les
capacités de tenir leurs engagements
est-ce que vous vous avez été témoin de
ces situations ou pas et puis la toute
dernière question il me semble que vous
n'avez pas pu répondre c'est la vie du
enfin le rapport de la Cour des comptes
concernant la liberté des prix propre
aux établissements de santé donc
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez merci pour
vos précisions
merci alors on va attacher de reprendre
certaines questions sur la question des
prix je vais commencer par là
on a effectivement de toute façon le
sentiment c'était l'avant-dernière et la
dernière question que les conditions
financières qui sont consenties aux
établissements de santé
contribuent et participent à un système
de régulation des prix du médicament qui
est un peu un peu à deux vitesses mais
ça a été dit lors de certains nombre
d'auditions devant cette cette
commission on a effectivement un certain
nombre de médicaments une fois qu'il
tombe dans le domaine public quelques
brevets sautes à des qui sont négociés à
des prix très bas et
des médicaments très innovants dont on
peut aussi derrière se poser la question
du système de financement de cette
innovation qui est particulièrement
socialiser et public et qui entraîne
effectivement cette fois-ci des prix
très haut voir même prohibitif pour un
certain nombre de traitements très
innovants mais le les conditions d'accès
à l'innovation pour les patients qui en
ont besoin nous on fait ce constat
évidemment aussi puisqu'on a l'occasion
d'aller sur les toutes les échelles de
prix et on plaide mais c'est j'allais
dire c'est des propositions qui sont
déjà dans le domaine public est-ce que
cet écart qui est vraiment très
important puisse se réduire on n'a pas
la main surtout la fixation des prix on
y contribue mais on n'a pas la main et
c'est ce qu'on a pu dire notamment dans
certaines missions pour lesquelles on a
été on a été auditionné
sur le sujet peut-être je vais laisser
Audric vous parler du sujet des critères
environnementaux puisqu'on a un exemple
assez parlant critérse environnementaux
sur un appel d'offre qu'on a mené
récemment pour vous éclairer sur ce
sujet
effectivement donc ça rejoint donc la
question des lieux de production que
l'on recense que l'on cartographie au
travers de nos appels d'offres et qui
sont intéressants dans leur évaluation
notamment sur le l'évaluation de
l'impact environnemental ou de son
estimation mais aussi sur d'autres
critères de d'analyse de risques que
l'on que l'on
détermine en fonction de la localisation
des sites de production des principaux
sites de production de leur de
l'éclatement de ces chaînes de
production
de la
de du niveau d'intégration de des sites
chez les différents acteurs et
éventuellement de la diversification
puisque on cherche nous à diversifier
nos approvisionnements au travers de
plusieurs fournisseurs mais nos propres
fournisseurs peuvent avoir les mêmes
stratégies et c'est des choses que nous
évaluons et que nous apprécions d'un
point de vue de la maîtrise du risque
sur la dimension environnementale
effectivement la localisation est
nous sert à une évaluation
sur les différentes
étapes les principales étapes la
production de matières premières la
production de produits final façonnage
et de manière plus dérogatoire sur le
sur le transport à proximé un impact
environnemental et donc elle valoriser
la mise en commun finalement je parle
des deux critères parce qu'il y a la
dimension environnementale et la
dimension de gestion du risque qui
conduisent et on a fait cette analyse je
vais vous en parler à valoriser
finalement des entreprises qui
produisent en circuit court et notamment
dans des pays européens
on a expérimenté ce secrétaire de choix
dans la consultation sur les
anti-infectieux et pour un quart des
lots sur lesquels donc nous avons
appliqué ces critères l'attribution a
été modifiée on a fait rétrospectivement
le le calcul des attributions si jamais
nous n'avions pas mis en place ces
critères et les résultats ont été
différents et ces résultats ont été
favorables à des sites de production
européens
sur votre question concernant
l'engagement des des industriels
effectivement nous pouvons constater à
plusieurs reprises un désengagement de
l'industriel entre le moment où il
répond à nos appels d'offres donc ce
qu'on appelle l'ADL ro la date limite de
remise de l'offre et le moment du
démarrage du marché ou il nous est
arrivé à plusieurs reprises d'avoir un
fournisseur qui d'une façon ou d'une
autre tente de se retirer sa promesse en
disant soit je n'ai plus les volumes
soit le prix auquel je vous ai répondu
puisqu'on s'inscrit quand même sur un
temps très long ça s'appelle d'offres
entre le moment où on commence à aller
travailler le moment où on les attribue
c'est un an de travail donc
effectivement les cours ces dernières
années on a vécu cette période de crise
et on a beaucoup parlé d'imprévisions et
donc effectivement on a un certain
nombre d'industriels qui nous ont dit on
vous a fait une proposition de prix il y
a 5 6 7 mois qui n'est absolument
aujourd'hui donc je souhaite être
désengagé de ma promesse vous comprenez
que ça
d'abord dans le cadre du code de la
grande public un c'est pas possible et
deux dans le dans le cadre de
l'organisation de nos hôpitaux c'est pas
possible non plus de jours au lendemain
de dire on n'a pas de fournisseur il
faut recommencer donc tout ça c'est
assez compliqué ça alourdit
considérablement le process mais c'est
notre travail d'acheteur donc d'arriver
à trouver dans la négo un terrain
d'entente qui permettent de continuer
approvisionner les établissements tout
en étant dans un surcoût tout à fait
contraint et qu'on puisse qu'on puisse
admettre maintenant sur la question des
coûts la seule question que je que j'ai
envie de poser c'est est-ce que
l'innovation devient le seul moyen de
financement de l'industrie
pharmaceutique puisque
parallèlement à ça enfin je m'occupe
aussi thérapie cellulaire de thérapie
génique effectivement ça a été dit on a
des coûts de traitement unitaires par
passion qui sont stratosphériques et à
côté de ça on a des molécules matures
certes elles sont matures mais le prix
est ridiculement bas et on a du mal à
connaître quel est le vrai prix de
revient d'un médicament quel est le vrai
prix de revient combien ça coûte la
production d'un médicament et même nous
dans ces métiers franchement il y a un
brouillard qui fait que on a un problème
de lisibilité
docteur Jacob oui donc nous peut-être
bon sur l'impact économique forcément
moi j'ai pas de chiffre là à vous donner
sur les établissements du réserve je
pourrais peut-être vous trouver
l'information et vous l'enfoiriez à
posteriori mais forcément il y a un
impact en surcoût puisque
de manière générale à un fournisseur qui
se trouve en défaillance
va enfin on va forcément aller chercher
auprès d'un autre fournisseur et le
problème qu'on a c'est que il y a pas de
limite dans le prix non plus du
fournisseur qui va substituer
l'alternative et donc on se retrouve
avec des surcoûts pour les
établissements qui vont avancer les
frais avec des procédures d'achat pour
compte qui parfois vont jusqu'au
contentieux puisque en fonction de le
moment où était la rupture est-ce que
j'étais en rupture est-ce que j'ai pas
en rupture finalement l'établissement
est impacté aussi par cette rupture en
termes de surcoût puisque
on a généralement pas un tarif qui est
préférentiel quand
on est en substituant à l'alternative
donc ça c'est sur le premier point j'ai
pas de chiffres là à vous avancer mon
pourra essayer de vous en apporter le
deuxième point c'est sur les exemples de
critères qu'on met sur la sécurisation
nous on a deux deux gros axes de
critères l'un qui est en prévention de
la rupture avec les moyens mis en oeuvre
pour garantir tout défaut d'approvision
d'approvisionnement ça rejoint
exactement ce que mes collègues Unies
achat font à savoir du recenser le
nombre de sources d'approvisionnement la
localisation le le type en matière
première mais également en produits
finis la localisation européenne voire
française si elle existe mais également
en cas de les moyens mis en cas de
rupture donc c'est les moyens mis en
oeuvre pour informer les disponibilités
des produits est-ce que on a des
propositions d'alternatives
d'importation est-ce qu'il y a des
modalités de règlement des pénalités je
tiendrai à rappeler quand même que la
pénalité justement
ça permet de responsabiliser quand même
un petit peu le fournisseur et justement
pour venir au point que vous abordiez
sur les engagements on a des cas en
effet alors j'ai pas là en tête de cas
précis sur un laboratoire qui s'est
engagé en amont et qui c'est tout de
suite retrouvé en défaillance mais ça
existe et donc c'est vrai que bah c'est
pénalité elle peut être dissuasives sur
sur
ces candidats là et c'est pour ça que on
souhaite les maintenir quand même dans
nos dans nos cahiers des charges sur la
RSE idem on a des critères qu'on a mis
en place on
on demande notamment des certifications
qui sont un petit peu des normes de mon
enfin en termes de responsabilité
sociétale et environnementale on regarde
aussi un petit peu au niveau du
transport s'il y a une optimisation des
tournées des optimisation des taux de
remplissage des camions s'il y a des
certifications éco-conduites ça c'est ce
que on commence à demander je dirais que
l'important c'est quand même aussi dans
la charge et là et l'importance
le nombre d'informations qu'on demande
aux fournisseurs ça serait quand même
plutôt intéressant que tant que centrale
d'achat on est une grille un peu commune
puisque ça permettrait aussi de
justement
réunir un peu les informations qu'on
demande et puis savoir comment on évalue
ces informations comment on note ces
informations puisque c'est en tant que
pharmacien pas forcément notre cœur de
métier mais ça va devenir puisque ça
prend une place de plus en plus
importante aussi dans nos critères
d'évaluation de nos produits au moment
où on passe les marchés
donc vraiment des critères qui peuvent
être communs ou pas mais en tout cas des
informations et des types de documents
qu'on demande qui sont bien en lien avec
l'objet du marché et une façon d'évaluer
qui qui serait intéressant de mettre
plutôt en commun aussi
et j'ai répondu je pense
aux questions de mes collègues
et bien merci beaucoup Alexandra bourche
fond teint merci madame la Présidente
mes chers collègues mesdames et
messieurs merci pour vos propos qui est
claire et aux travaux je voulais juste
vous interroger sur les outils et les
technologies que vous utilisez pour
suivre et gérer la chaîne
d'approvisionnement en médicaments je
suppose que vous avez recours à
l'intelligence artificielle je crois que
certains d'entre vous sont passés par
Accenture
si oui donc comment vous pouvez comment
vous l'utilisez en tout cas pour
améliorer justement la traçabilité et
puis la transparence de la chaîne
justement d'approvisionnement de
médicaments
je fais une salle de questions et après
Laurence Muller Braun
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs merci pour vos
éclaircissements
l'hôpital étant l'acteur le plus exposé
en situation de crise avez-vous un accès
prioritaire
aux médicaments et devrait-il y en avoir
un si ce n'est pas le cas
vous avez été confronté à la pénurie de
médicaments en soins intensifs pendant
la crise sanitaire quelles leçons
avez-vous pu en tirer
avez-vous établi vous-même à travers
votre réseau une liste de molécules
critiques et de produits de santé
indispensable indispensables merci
emiliane
oui merci madame la Présidente merci de
votre exposé vous avez évoqué vous-même
le problème du prix et vous avez dit
vous même vous n'avez pas de
transparence et que vous aviez du mal un
petit peu à vous y retrouver on a le
sentiment vous écoutant qu'il y a quand
même une sorte quelque part de chantage
à le dire en répondant à l'appel
d'offres et puis après on dit oui mais
ça a été trop long mais c'est pas assez
c'est pas les prix négociés c'était trop
loin donc on a l'impression que les Big
Pharma font un espèce de chantage et
j'aimerais savoir ce qui selon vous
justifie l'écart énorme qui peut y avoir
effectivement avec des prix de produits
matures qui sont extrêmement bas
qu'est-ce qui justifie d'avoir des prix
aussi élevés vous avez parlé de prix
stratosphérique je reprends votre terme
sur les médicaments
innovants personne n'arrive à nous
expliquer comment on peut arriver au
prix de 1 million ou 2 millions d'euros
le traitement pour certaines pathologies
en particulier dans une thérapie génique
alors que effectivement une boîte de
doliprane d'amoxicilline c'est quelques
euros
merci la présidente moi je vous ai
entendu je trouve que vous avez beaucoup
d'attente sur sur l'Union européenne
en revanche est-ce que vous connaissez
bien les contraintes de l'Union
européenne parce que ça je le dis pour
tout le monde c'est que dans les traités
la compétence santé n'est pas une
compétence pleine c'est juste une
compétence d'appui donc la seule chose
qu'on puisse faire c'est effectivement
comme on a fait pendant le covid c'est à
dire des partenariats des des ententes
pour pour essayer de trouver on va dire
une solution au problème mais ça ne peut
pas se généraliser parce que bien
souvent en fait au niveau de l'Union
européenne il faut que les 27 soit
d'accord tous ensemble et c'est quand
même quelque chose de compliqué donc
voilà
moi j'entends beaucoup vos critères les
volumes etc toutes ces contraintes là
elles sont pas les mêmes chez les
Allemands sont pas les mêmes dans
d'autres pays est-ce que on ajoute pas
nous en France encore justement des
critères aux critères en
ce aussi
et qui font que en même temps que les
prix qui sont contraints en France
davantage que dans les autres pays
européennes font que une entreprise elle
a plutôt intérêt à vendre ailleurs que
que chez nous et moi c'était une des
d'ailleurs on a une
comment une fédération qui du médicament
qui avait demandé à être reçu mais dans
le cadre de notre commission des
affaires européennes et c'est ce qui
nous avait dit en fait c'est que même
une des personnes parce que c'était des
tpeme qui avait acheté une entreprise et
qui vendait uniquement en dehors de la
France justement pour une question de de
prix et donc de rentabilité par rapport
à un investissement en fait donc je me
dis quelle solution en fait trouver à ça
parce que la pénurie elle est partout ça
on l'a bien entendu mais en revanche
chez nous elle est accentuée toutes ces
raisons là une raison aussi de
surconsommation souvent de médicaments
aussi
je vais compléter par mes questions
pour avoir quelques précisions n'avez
pas répondu sur le coup des pénuries
c'est ce que vous avez vu vous c'est une
question comment dire au sens propre au
sens piqurait puisqu'il y a un coût en
santé publique et en économie de la
santé donc et je pense forcément avec
les substitutions que vous êtes
confrontés à ce genre de sujet en tout
cas les hôpitaux le sont sur le terrain
c'est une certitude
donc ça c'est ma première question ma
deuxième question
concerne vos choix parce qu'on a on a
beaucoup vous avez évoqué la question
des médicaments matures du fait que il y
a des choix de diminution importantes de
prix même en deçà du coup de fabrication
des médicaments eux-mêmes pour des
médicaments pourtant essentiels et
indispensable pour un certain nombre
et est-ce que dans vos stratégies vous
avez tendance à privilégier les
génériques par exemple est-ce que
puisque du point de vue hospitalier
beaucoup beaucoup de de professionnels
vont arriver beaucoup de génériques dans
les services et donc peuvent pas garder
les princesses ou un certain nombre de
princesses auxquelles ils ont vous savez
très bien prescripteur a parfois un peu
ses habitudes de prescription et c'est
quand même un sujet sur le terrain au
niveau hospitalier ma troisième question
porte sur le CEPS comment s'articule
votre politique du prix puisque quelque
part vous intervenez dans la politique
du prix du médicament même si c'est pas
le cri prix en public c'est le prix
hôpital mais quand même avec les choix
qui sont faits dans les négociations et
les contractualisations avec le CEPS en
B2B entre les laboratoires et le CEPS
est-ce que est-ce qu'il y a des hiatus
est-ce que vous êtes mieux 10 ans moins
10 ans est-ce que voilà est-ce que vous
avez une stratégie qui se fait en
collaboration en coopération pour voir
Créer des des concurrences en quelque
sorte entre l'hôpital d'un côté et puis
la ville de l'autre et puis ma dernière
question
euh porte sur les fameuses appels les
méga appel d'offres et la pénurie en
réalité peut-être que c'est quelque
chose qui se corrige maintenant mais il
y a eu un moment où les médias appel
d'offrent notamment un concomitament
avec l'arrivée des génériques et la
libéralisation d'un certain nombre de
comment dire de formule qui sont revenus
dans le domaine public etc à ce
moment-là
il y a eu des mégas appel d'offres parce
que l'objectif était effectivement de
diminuer les dépenses de santé au
travers du médicament et il y a eu un
effet d'assèchement sur la production en
tout cas sur le plan européen c'est
certain
mais sur le plan international des
formes de monopole parce que une
rationalisation qui dirationalisation
dit moins de monde sur le sur le terrain
pour produire donc vous la tendance est
à renverser cette situation il n'empêche
qu'on a bien eu pour certains
médicaments ça restait quand même un
très très gros sujet et donc est-ce que
de la part des pouvoirs publics il y a
une demande une commande auprès de vous
pour être co-constructeur y compris au
niveau européen comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même de ce retour en arrière des
monopoles
alors je vais commencer par répondre à
votre à votre dernière question oui et
c'est assumé est-ce que j'ai dit en
introduction il y a eu effectivement par
la massification la recherche d'économie
dans un contexte et c'est important
aussi de regarder ça du point de vue des
industriels ou à un moment le
l'industrie pharmaceutique était très
concentré entre quelques quelques
laboratoires et on a vu une évolution
notamment avec le générique de
producteurs pour le compte d'industriel
qui aujourd'hui pour un certain nombre
de gros industriels ne fabriquent plus
eux-mêmes les médicaments et le délay
donc effectivement des petits acteurs
sont arrivés et ça rejoint une des
questions qui étaient posées sur comment
nous aussi en tant que centrale d'achat
et c'est une préoccupation qu'on a on
accompagne certaines entreprises qui
sont parfois confrontées à la difficulté
de répondre à des appels d'offres cette
complexité nous on préfère ne pas
baisser notre niveau d'exigence de de
complexité parfois peut être perçu comme
tel parce que c'est ce qu'on doit nos
hôpitaux et à nous adhérents c'est de
traduire leurs besoins avec des appels
d'offres qui peuvent effectivement
paraître complexes multiplicité de
critères des choses qui sont parfois
difficiles à percevoir et qu'elle si
difficile de répondre pour une petite
entreprise mais d'accompagner aussi ces
entreprises parce qu'on peut le faire et
on doit le faire et certainement
d'acteurs et d'acheteurs publics
notamment
on a beaucoup à prendre des
collectivités territoriales qui ont de
l'avance là-dessus pour accompagner les
acteurs notamment de leur écosystème
territorial sur l'accès à la commande
publique donc ça on a des choses à faire
et c'est une des préoccupations pour
revenir sur un certain nombre de
questions les outils et technologiques
utilisés oui nous avons un processus de
monter en charge en termes de système
d'information c'est évidemment un sujet
clé notamment parce que nous avons cette
ambition que j'ai donné en introduction
d'être
à terme établissement pharmaceutique
donc de gérer aussi l'approvisionnement
c'est-à-dire tout le circuit de commande
de la commande jusqu'à la délivrance
[Musique]
qu'on a avec les instances européennes
notamment la Commission européenne c'est
plus effectivement des partenariats il y
a un club qui s'appelle le club des big
buyers qui effectivement permet de
partager d'échanger sur les projets et
d'aller chercher avec les industriels
des déboucher parce que encore une fois
quand on discute avec des industriels
sur des projets de relocalisation de
fabrication de molécules critique sur le
sol français ou européen les débouchés
du ni achat et ou des hôpitaux français
sont jamais suffisants donc il faut
qu'on aille chercher des débouchés
ailleurs sans forcément passer par par
les instances qui sont effectivement un
peu plus complexes à appréhender le coût
des pénuries c'est une question à
laquelle il est difficile de répondre
pour nous parce qu'on n'est pas on n'est
pas dans les hôpitaux donc on a des
difficultés à mesurer je les dis tout à
l'heure le coût pour un hôpital en terme
déjà de ressources humaines de
travailler sur aller chercher des
substitutions aller même faire le marché
c'est le rôle qu'on joue à la place des
hôpitaux quand on parle des circuits
d'approvisionnement on est effaré de
voir encore à l'hôpital et c'est pas une
critique c'est un constat des circuits
d'approvisionnement de commande qui sont
très peu dématérialisées en utilisant
encore beaucoup le fax aujourd'hui à
l'hôpital pour commander les médicaments
on a une réalité on a des circuits de
commande je discutais avec un pharmacien
sans Hospitalier Universitaire disait
l'autre toujours il a 600 fournisseurs
600 fournisseurs c'est 600 factures à
traiter donc c'est autant de temps à
Jean qui va prendre la facture vérifier
qu'elle est bien effectivement qu'elle
correspond bien à une commande et une
livraison et ensuite la mandatée donc
tout ça on a un gisement de productivité
important à la fois économique et
écologique sur lequel on travaille sur
un niveau national parce que encore une
fois le niveau régional il a malgré tout
du mal à trouver son retour sur
investissement et son équilibre
économique et des études qui ont été
faites là-dessus donc nous on est
convaincu que c'est le niveau national
qu'il faut pour se positionner comme
grossiste répartiteur je vous le dis de
manière un peu pas forcément tout à fait
c'est pas forcément le bon terme mais
c'est ce qu'on souhaite faire du
médicament hospitalier ce qui nous
permettra de mobiliser des leviers et de
rationaliser les circuits de commande
hospitaliers encore une fois de la
commande jusqu'à la facturation et de
redonner du temps aux hôpitaux parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a effectivement le
sentiment que ça coûte sans qu'on puisse
malheureusement et je suis désolé de pas
pouvoir répondre à cette question je
laisse peut-être mes collègues oui juste
une réponse sur le CEPS aucun lien on le
on le déplore nous n'avons aucun lien
avec le CPS aucun lien absolument aucun
et on souhaite on souhaiterait pardon
allez-y mais on aimerait bien on
aimerait bien non mais nous non plus
on a discuté ces sujets là notamment une
audition sur la rémission de régulation
de financement des produits de santé
effectivement c'est un souhait qu'on
aurait parce qu'on aurait je pense des
choses à se dire ça c'est sûr et des
choses à travailler ensemble mais
aujourd'hui les liens n'existent pas
je vous laisse peut-être compléter sur
des exemples
non non c'était pour aller dans le sens
de nos collègues que nous non plus on
n'a pas de contact direct on a les avis
de prix aux JO comme comme tous les
établissements de santé
peut-être moi je veux juste compléter
par rapport à puisque pour répondre un
peu à la même question avant de laisser
plutôt la parole au pharmacien mais sur
sur l'outil pour gérer la chaîne
d'approvisionnement comme il n'y achat
nous on est plutôt sur le processus de
commande publique de passation des
contrats qu'on exécute pas ce sont nos
hôpitaux adhérents qui vont exécuter
donc on ne gère pas toute cette chaîne
d'approvisionnement par contre comme on
voulait indiquer plutôt là dans nos
échanges on pense que c'est un endroit
où il faut aller creuser parce que sur
toute cette chaîne d'approvisionnement
c'est c'est voilà il y a la performance
à faire rentrer il y a des des gains à
faire sur tout ce système aujourd'hui on
a simplement un outil pour gérer pas les
ruptures mais en tout cas l'information
transmise à nos adhérents sur les
ruptures qui est un outil de dialogue
entre les laboratoires le raisin en tant
qu'ordonnateur et les adhérents voilà on
a on a cet outil là qui qui a toute
petite partie de la pro mais après on
n'a pas de système pour pour gérer la
totalité puisque chaque hôpital
aujourd'hui
gère son approvisionnement en direct
madame Bardet juste deux compléments sur
les sur les surcos alors évidemment
l'ingénierie contractuelle nous permet
quand même de tenter de nous prémunir
avec notamment dès l'attribution des
marchés on a un attributeur de rang 1 et
de un attributeur de rang 2 avec lequel
on a déjà
négocié un prix ce qui permet de nous
prémunir des comportements prédateurs de
certains fournisseurs ce qu'on a eu à
subir de nombreuses fois donc ça
maintenant c'est à peu près encadré et
de façon à ce que les hôpitaux ne payent
pas le prix fort quand on est vraiment
au pied du mur et qu'on est prêt à payer
n'importe quel prix pour avoir le
produit donc ça c'était le premier
témoignage vous m'avez posé une question
est-ce que vous favoriser les génériques
à l'hôpital non pas du tout en favorise
le mieux disant selon nos critères donc
parfois c'est le principe qui gagne
parfois c'est le générique mais il y a
absolument pas de volonté de notre part
de favoriser l'un plutôt que l'autre
et le dernier témoignage que je voulais
faire parce qu'on parle beaucoup des
médicaments aujourd'hui c'est l'objet de
cette réunion mais les dispositifs
médicaux il y a la pénurie sur les
dispositifs médicaux et quelque chose
d'extrêmement prévenant et qui est
encore plus
facteur de désorganisation dans nos
établissements parce qu'autant pour les
médicaments nous pharmaciens avant la
compétence contrairement par exemple aux
officinaux à l'hôpital on a la capacité
de faire de la substitution et de
définir des équivalences et de pouvoir
être très réactif et mettre à
disposition de nos prescripteurs un plan
B autant le dispositif médical notamment
le dispositif médical un peu technique
il est très opérateur dépendant il peut
y avoir une courbe d'apprentissage et là
c'est extrêmement déstabilisant et
dernier témoignage sur un produit
frontière mais qui est aussi dans le
périmètre pharmaceutique qui sont les
solutions hydro-alcooliques dont j'ai la
charge pour inachat et pour éviter
effectivement un monopole de fait et
d'arroser la totalité du territoire
français avec le même fournisseur on
avait tenté des lots géographiques donc
on a coupé la France en quatre et donc
sur les solutions hydroalcooliques le
problème c'est qu'il faut que ce soit
extrêmement bien toléré par les
soignants parce que sinon si ça leur
arrache la moitié de la peau très vite
elles vont les soignants vont dire non
mais j'arrête j'utilise pas ce qui n'est
pas du tout le l'enjeu et l'objectif et
donc on est obligé de faire des essais
assez longs et notamment en période
hivernale qui est la période pendant
laquelle la peau et la plus fragile et à
l'issue de ses essais en fait les quatre
régions quelle que soit la météo
puisqu'il fait pas la même météo à Lille
qui à Marseille mais en tout cas les
quatre régions ont souhaité travailler
avec le même fournisseur donc ce que je
vais vous dire c'est qu'on a beau avoir
une ingénérique contractuelle qui nous
permet nous prémunir des potentiels
ruptures d'approvisionnement pour autant
on abandonne
on n'abandonne pas la qualité
et devant un critère qui serait
économique par exemple c'est sur ces
sujets là c'est la qualité qui prime
donc ça signifie que vous avez des
retours aussi des services hospitaliers
par exemple sur certains médicaments qui
ont été retenus et
bien sûr
oui oui il y a un suivi d'exécution tout
au long de l'exécution du marché on a
des retours qu'on connaît et on en fait
un Rex pour l'itération suivante et on
tient compte de ces différents
témoignages
peut-être pour compléter sur la question
sur la liste des des molécules critiques
donc oui nous en réalisons des listes
des short listes et c'est ce que
j'évoquais dans mon propos tout à
l'heure sur et c'est ce qui définit la
stratégie d'achat finalement qui va être
déployé et c'est typiquement sur ces
médicaments que l'on juge critiquent de
par leur place dans l'arsenal
thérapeutique et de la structuration de
leur chaîne de d'approvisionnement
éventuellement des éléments que l'on
aurait pu détecter en termes de
dépendance vis-à-vis de certaines zones
géographiques sur certains aspects par
exemple la production de matières
premières ou de manière moins évidente
sur le le façonnage et donc la stratégie
de diversification porte en priorité sur
ces molécules là sur les autres
molécules celles par ailleurs où nous
avons des parts de marché qui sont
relativement modérés parce que par
exemple les médicaments sont aussi
disponibles sur le circuit ville nous
avons plutôt recours à l'attribution
avec un rang 1 et un rang 2 avec la
précontractualisation finalement qui
nous donne
une réactivité plus grande au moment de
l'arrivée d'une rupture avec un prix qui
est pré-contactualisé peut-être sur la
notion du surcoût donc comme cela a été
expliqué nos marchés prévois que le
différentiel de coups que l'on n'aurait
en recourant un deuxième attributaire ou
un autre fournisseur au moins d'une
rupture et te porter à la charge de
celui qui a été défaillant dans
l'ingénierie contractuelle que l'on
développe notamment sur les molécules
critiques et dans la mesure où les
niveaux de prix qui sont contractualisés
entre les deux attributaires qui font
l'objet d'une zone d'attribution sont à
peu près proches nous avons modifié
finalement et cette clause n'était plus
nécessairement pertinente et quand elle
a été remplacée plutôt par une modalité
de pénalité en réalité ce qui finalement
génère des recettes ou un dédommagement
on pourrait plutôt appeler ça un
dédommagement pour l'établissement
plutôt que un jeu de passation de
trésorerie comme ce qui se
s'opère quand on a recours à de l'achat
pour compte
et peut-être pour la question sur le
hiatus entre les molécules matures et
les molécules innovantes en fait la
modalité de détermination de ces prix
n'est absolument pas la même les
molécules innovantes pour l'objet d'une
évaluation
médico-économique là où les molécules
matures sont par le jeu de la
concurrence les prix sont déterminés je
parle pour ce qui est de des prix
hospitaliers pas des prix réglementées
en ville sont finalement calqués
définies par l'industriel au vu des
exigences de nos contrats et en fonction
de son coût de revient industriel donc
c'est peut-être ce qui explique qu'il y
a potentiellement une grande différence
puisque le coin industriel n'est pas le
critère de
détermination du prix pour les
molécules innovantes
alors
oui
vous avez toute une structuration mais
lorsque les prix sont réglementés c'est
le CEPS qui infinait attribue un prix de
remboursement pour ces prix c'est ce
qu'on a eu à l'issue de l'audition de
ceps
est-ce qu'il peut arriver que vous payez
plus cher un médicament
en théorie non
en théorie non et dans la pratique
clairement pas même si c'est assez
difficile de comparer puisque nous avons
connaissance des prix qui sont
réglementés qui sont des prix faciaux
nous ne connaissons pas le montant des
remises etc donc je ne saurais pas je
n'avancerai pas sur le niveau le la
comparaison néanmoins par rapport au
prix facial c'est certain que nos prix
du fait du jeu de la concurrence sont
inférieurs et sont déterminés par les
industriels eux-mêmes au moment de la
réponse à leur appels d'offres sur la
base des éléments que j'ai apporté pour
les
bien merci beaucoup on a tenu les délais
merci pour
vos réponses si complète et puis
on vous fera parvenir peut-être un
questionnaire complémentaire si
nécessaire et n'hésitez pas à nous faire
part de vos réflexions plus merci
beaucoup